you released a special what's up next
what's your next project my next project
is begging to be in one of these Boston
movies I'm so sick of not getting cast
in these May I want to be in Manchester
by the sea the [ __ ] I'm from Boston I
can do the accent it's got a good yeah
you got the accent yeah can we just do
an audition right now sure of course
yeah this might be a director watching
and this is gonna be my son Tommy it's
called the Chou's River you work at the
docks I just brought home some Duncan
hey Tommy I brought you your eyes a pen
Tommy are you high I said you can live
in my basement have a beer or two if you
want but but when you start doing drugs
Tommy that's an you take advantage of me
what's you dirtbag friend is he it you
know I worked at and yo his father died
twice and I couldn't afford the second
funeral so take it getting disrespected
in my own house
thank you
the Charles River coming out in Chara
and I'm the Sun I like I'm the idiot saw
me I'm a dirtbag you're a wicked dirtbag
you